tens of thousands of airline workers are
out of jobs this weekend
the federal government's 25 billion
payroll support program has expired
along with a ban on airline job cuts now
while there's a chance that congress and
the white house could provide
new aid the enormous number of furloughs
we are already seeing
could deal a major blow to the overall
economy chris van cleave has the story
united flight attendant annette holla
lost her dream
job to covid i love my job
the thought of losing it's really hard
right now
and she's not alone about 45 thousand
airline employees were subject to be
furloughed or laid off starting october
first
congress is still trying to agree on a
measure to renew the expired payroll
support program that would keep everyone
working
hala worries how she'll pay for the home
she bought in february
if that help doesn't come i can't really
imagine not having a paycheck
and health insurance is really big
at least another 44 000 airline workers
took exit packages and have left their
jobs
more than 74 000 others have taken
unpaid leave
and that trouble on the tarmac goes far
beyond the terminal as commercial
aviation helps support another 10.4
million u.s
workers that's one out of every 14 jobs
like the one 62-year-old teresa santucci
lost
i'm basically squeaking by she was among
the 50-plus who worked on alaska's
in-flight magazine which shut down after
the airline pulled it from their planes
a day later we're all emptying out our
offices you can't get
any more sudden or unexpected than that
this dallas business was left holding
the bag tens of thousands of bags
of nuts the airlines can't use business
is down
80 percent the pandemic is also
devastating the airport parking industry
which employed about twelve thousand
pre-covet
lost business totaling 400 million
dollars and counting
in march the ceiling fell our business
just
disappeared into thin air rob chavez's
family has owned fast park
for 60 years he had to lay off 60
percent of his staff
that's 540 people dejuan roberts was one
of them
good morning he was furloughed for
nearly four months
what's that like bad it was
bad for me he's finally back working but
only part time
does that cover your bills it's helping
right now but
really it's not for cbs this morning
saturday
chris vancleave baltimore